es un momento crucial y se saca la
decisión de la corte suprema fue
aplazada hasta este jueves unos 6000
indígenas de 170 etnias ataviados con
sus coloridas vestimentas tradicionales
resisten en los improvisados campamentos
bajo el lema lucha por la vida y es que
el futuro de sus territorios y
comunidades ancestrales dependen del
fallo grandes propietarios y aliados de
jair bolsonaro quieren legalizar el
despojo a los indígenas impidiendo el
reconocimiento legal de sus tierras si
no estaban físicamente allí en
1988 incluso si los habían expulsado el
máximo tribunal de brasilia debe decidir
sobre el denominado marco temporal por
el que los pueblos originarios de brasil
sólo tendrían derecho a la tierra si
estaban habitando la antes de 1988
cuando se ratificó la constitución del
país para los activistas y nativos la
norma supondría una nueva expropiación
de su territorio en la amazonía que
durante décadas se ha visto amenazado
tanto por la colonización como las
guerras y más recientemente la feroz
deforestación
queremos cuidar nuestros territorios
nuestros mayores y niños por eso estamos
en brasilia para obtener algún
reconocimiento porque la gente no nos
reconoce como verdaderos brasileños por
eso ocupamos brasilia hoy para mostrarle
a brasil y al mundo que no morimos
estamos vivos y somos la historia viva
de brasil
los activistas dicen que la decisión de
la corte podría ser el fallo del ciclo y
el posible desplazamiento de las
comunidades de sus resguardos que será
un duro golpe para el mantenimiento de
la selva amazónica y cuyo papel es clave
frente a la lucha contra el cambio
climático